[Music]
is violence ever justified in the
pursuit of political or social aims and
where it is justified how can we
actually argue for it to discuss and
debate that particular issue we have a
stellar panel here on my left hand side
is Professor Steven Pinker of Harvard
University one of the best-known public
intellectuals in the world on the right
hand side from where I'm sitting
tariq Ali also one of the world's
best-known public intellectuals and to
my immediate right here is Elif sorry
Jon who is an activist in the Kurdish
women's movement and UK coordinator of
the Kurdistan Students Union would you
please welcome our panel here today I
got to start by opening up the debate
with three short statements from our key
speakers in which they look at various
aspects of the question of violence and
its place in politics and society and
Tariq can I start with you I'm going to
ask the straight question to which I
think I know the simple answer but I'd
love to hear your take on it
are there occasions when the use of
violence can and should be justified in
seeking political ends I think so and I
think history teaches us that I mean
there are of course different forms of
violence I'm not and never have been a
supporter of terrorism defined as it
should be defined either individual or
that used by States but I am a strong
supporter of historically speaking of
all the revolutions that have taken
place the slave rebellions that have
taken place in history starting if you
like with the American Revolution
against British colonialism carrying on
to the French Revolution the revolution
of the Enlightenment the link between
the intellectuals prior to the
Revolution and the revolutionaries was
very strong the English revolution
which laid the foundations of democracy
which is why Cromwell statue is still
outside the House of Commons so far no
one has argued that it should be removed
though they don't allow stamps with
Cromwell's head on it because it
requires the Monarchs head on a tutu and
of course in the 20th century we've had
a whole wave of revolutions and
revolutionary struggles which have
deployed violence the Russian Revolution
the Chinese Vietnamese Cuban the huge
anti-colonial struggles waged by the
Vietnamese so I'm afraid it's very
difficult studying modern all medieval
history or early modern history to get
away from this idea of violence and I
think we have to detach the violence
used by masses in motion from acts of
individual terror carried out for
whatever reason or suicide terrorism or
or whatever I mean the struggle of
people for their freedom has always
involved violence because the people
they're trying to gain independence from
deploy it as well so the choice is
either to sit down and do nothing or to
hope that peaceful agitation wins today
which it never has with very few
exceptions and and to throw the power
open to those who occupy oppress and
kill people
ad nauseam I mean this goes on today
even as we're sitting here six walls are
being waged in the United in the world
by the United States the most brutal of
which which is hardly mentioned is the
war in the Yemen being waged by Saudi
Arabia and its allies backed by the
United States in Britain so what are the
poor Yemenis to do thanks very much
indeed you may well discuss exactly that
point in just a few minutes but let's
turn first to Steven Pinker Steven we've
heard that case that peaceful engagement
on its own simply hasn't been a useful
way of changing society with the
exception of a very few cases you
spoken out for better angels career very
publicly would you agree with the case
that tarik has made no I wouldn't agree
I guess I start from the premise that
killing people is bad and killing more
people is worse than killing fewer
people so even though I also don't
support terrorism our terrorists have
killed a tiny number of people the worst
terrorist attack in history 9/11 killed
3,000 typical terrorist attack kills a
handful
whereas Wars and revolutions kill people
by the millions and tens of millions and
often it is true tarik listed a number
of violent events in human history we do
not make the argument that these are are
good or justifiable these were history's
disasters now I do believe that there
are arguments that there can be
occasions in which violence is justified
if it is the only way to prevent greater
violence again I'm assuming that that
murdering people is bad you disagree
with that then you can disagree with the
whole argument and that murdering two
million people 4 million people 20
million people is really really bad now
did the events that we just heard result
in the reduction of violence prevention
of killing of even greater numbers which
I suppose could be used as a utilitarian
argument justifying violence the answer
is in virtually all the cases no the
French Revolution was a disaster killed
2 million people
led to the rise of Napoleon from perhaps
the world's first totalitarian fascist
dictator who began wars of conquest that
killed another an additional four
million people led to the restoration of
slavery to the restoration of the
monarchy and a delay of democracy in
France by perhaps a century Russian
Revolution killed several million led to
the Russian civil war which killed
another nine million led to the rise of
Stalin who killed 20 million there's an
old cliche you can't make an omelet
without breaking a few eggs well it
ignores the fact that people aren't eggs
and that generally does not result in an
omelet again the Chinese revolution
perhaps the most disastrous event in
history led to the Great Leap Forward
and the
Cultural Revolution we've killed perhaps
32 to 40 million people altogether
time and again a violent revolution
violent war in addition to the moral
harm of mass murder and again I mean
murder we're talking about millions or
tens of millions of people does not
result in a stable peaceful state that
saves the lives of even more quite the
contrary
you know a recent study by Maria Stephan
and Erica Chenoweth actually looked over
the last century at violent and
nonviolent resistant movement resistance
movements to put the Gandhian hypothesis
to a test that it that there are ways of
overcoming tyranny using the all of the
tactics that that Gandhi worked out now
you could of course be cynical about the
Gandhian hypothesis by saying well he
tugged at the heartstrings of of the
British at an opportune moment and he
just got lucky so they decided to count
of the all of the resistance movements
of the 20th century they divided them
into violent ones and nonviolent ones
putting aside the question of which was
more moral that is which murdered fewer
people just asked the question of which
is more effective now it's not the case
that violent resistance movements always
succeed or the non violent ones fail or
vice versa
but if you count them up they found that
nonviolent resistance movements were
three times as effective as violent ones
doesn't mean the vile ones are never
effective but even in terms of sheer
efficacy the nonviolent ones tend to
have a higher success when you say three
times as effective Steven do you mean
they killed one-third as few people no
they three times more often they
resulted in regime change
okay that's an interesting definition
and one that I think we will have to
come back and lead in the discussion of
final observation is that in in a survey
of what leads to stable democracies
inspired in part by the 2003 invasion of
Iraq which I think we all agree was not
a successful measure to to install a
peaceful liberal democracy in that
actually fits into a pattern that
decapitations of a existing tyrannical
regime generally don't result in a
stable democracy well that with one
final observation I'm Canadian so we
actually did achieve independence from
Britain nonviolent way and we took a
little bit longer than the United States
but the American Revolution was a pretty
bloody and and brutal mess as well and
Canada has a result it is today one of
the most stable least violent and most
democratic societies on earth so much so
they're a prominent politician in this
country who want Britain now to become
Canada or something called Canada plus
plus plus
Thank You Stephen Ellie started young
you know a great deal but in theory and
in practice about the way in which
coercion and violence and resistance
have been used in certain very prominent
recent conflicts I wonder if you could
give us your thoughts in the next couple
of minutes so I think when we talk about
whether violence or conflict is
necessary for some sort of lasting
change I think it's important when we
discuss these the framework in which we
discuss them in terms of you know we
don't have the time for that right now
but even to acknowledge you know the
history and the roots of the ideas of
war and essentially you know people mass
murdering each other for you know
whatever purpose or whatever means it
may be and I think from the historical
references that we have access to I
think it's quite I think we can quite
comfortably say that the history and the
roots of war also the history on roots
of patriarchy for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute's of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you